Humans kill at least 100 million sharks a
year, or about 11,000 an hour.
If everyone in the world washed their hands
properly, a million lives could be saved a
year.
The Pentagon has actually created an emergency
plan in case of a zombie attack.
Steve Jobs held important business meetings
whilst walking, because our brains work better
whilst the body is physically active.
A Blackpool hotel charged a couple a £100
fine after they wrote a TripAdvisor review
describing it as a "dirty, rotten stinking
hovel run by muppets."
Queen Elizabeth II of England owns a drive-through
McDonald's as part of her enormous property
portfolio.
To help panda cubs adapt to living in the
wild, researchers at a panda centre in China
wear panda costumes whilst working with them.
Male kangaroos are known to flex their biceps
to impress female kangaroos.
Most bees buzz in the key of A, unless they
are tired, when they buzz in the key of E.
In 2011, a woman bought a non-visible piece
of art for $10,000, entitled "Fresh Air".
Mr. Kanso is a popular Japanese restaurant
that only serves tinned food.
Diners get to select their meal from a huge
variety of tinned food from the shelves.
A woman who survived a plane bomb explosion
in 1972 was awarded the Guinness World Record
title for the highest fall without a parachute
at 33,000 feet.
Women buy 85% of the world's Valentine cards
and 96% of all the candles in America.
Panda eat bamboo for at least 12 hours a day.
The Indonesian volcano Kawah Ijen produces
blue flames from its lava because of its high
sulphur content.
A single human male produces enough sperm
in a fortnight to impregnate every fertile
woman on the planet.